oh yes yep your game 2016 so showing up
we've seen drew ok we've seem like the
Joffrey esque look-alike yeah he was
like half dragon kills of styles gotta
play guns whatever this time it's all
about dragons yep
the cool bit the cool bit and you can do
a lot with those dragons apparently yeah
yeah deeply off eugene and our deeper
customization system girls you can
basically it's basically jurassic world
yes so you take there are different
variants of dragons with different
strengths and weaknesses and you can
basically manipulate the DNA in dragon
shrines using those gems you collect
when you defeat enemies to create the
ultimate free yeah so it's like a three
step process you pick up base dragon and
it has a selection of it's basically a
cloth so you get like the Rex which is
you know kind of like the heavier type I
believe and a waiver and they will have
like unique capability some are better
at taking damage some are good at you
know giving damage balance speed that
kind of thing and from there you
essentially use those shrines that
evolve them and add on traits from other
types of dragons create the Andromeda's
yeah so you can like take a tank dragon
and give it some wings by mixing DNA and
then give it like a bit of a speed boost
and then the third part is Alma yeah
inevitably what happens is when you
evolve this dragon into like a hybrid
dragon it will always have some sort of
like deficiency in terms of one of the
one attribute or another you cover up
for that lightly finds a way yeah it
always and you cover up for that using
honor yeah which is also really
customizable but it also just it can get
damaged and fight so you have to repair
yes yeah what I want to do is have
everyone create this you need dragon and
it has opened a kind of like discussion
about you can create dumb dragons to try
and make the game difficult like you can
create a fat Rex which is like a rex
merged with another ex which essentially
makes them even slower and tankier than
before and not as like versatile as the
other dragons so it could be a way of
doing like a dark soul soul level one
like the new run essentially but yeah
it's like trying to create unique
dragons that are you know your style and
the evolution are they lets you create a
unique kind of like form of the dragon
it's not going to be a you know standard
looking dragon or women they have a
weird hybrid except dragon except
dragons are way better yeah the other
thing they were showing is yes you
control drew but there is also you know
troop had this bond with the dragon
Thuban and dragon linked dragon link is
the name for that bond so basically what
happens if you're in the middle of a
fight
you know we saw in the demo Swampert
yeah we bought something called a one
puff yeah like quite a large abominable
snowman monkey thing yeah something like
that but it was like this monkey type
that was really aggressive jumping at
the enemy same size with the dragon yeah
obviously drew can't take it on by
himself but he views it the dragon link
you sort of like drew will will stop
yeah he knocks into place got a first
person and you're controlling the dragon
- phew - a playable character and you
can just Wayne fire with that dragon and
basically work together attack its weak
spot for massive damage yeah so what
they wanted to emphasize with this
mechanic was their games are known for
being combo heavy style heavy and they
haven't explored that too much and the
way they're doing it is it's not
something that's not exactly like buying
it always frame precise execution it's
more like if you very intelligent and
use your skills together you can do poor
stuff
so in that fight there was it like a set
up a scowling phase where drew was
running around the Whomper and trying
see what he can do and squatted there
like a weak point on the leg and then he
switched to the dragon link where you
see his hand just in the middle of the
screen and then commanded the dragon
Thuban
to kind of like push him over and then
he did like a ground pound which
essentially locked him in place and he
likes wholly held him down essentially
yeah and then through running out front
activate his dragon hybrid mode and bam
bam bam bam so it's that kind of thing
and they want you to develop it it's the
thing that was missing form for me from
scalebound was the flare and the kind of
the unique combat hook to it it seemed
like a very much like a kind of like you
know you got this dragon and you're
fighting here and there but the fact
that they've revealed you can control
the dragon now it adds a new wrinkle a
bit of texture to the combat mechanics
that makes it more interesting for me
and for the people who like the
traditional deep PlatinumGames
lot of numbers yeah a lot of stat yep
stay tuned to games Broadcom dragons oh
cool
feta cops